هذا المكان
معروف
بالنار الزرقاء اللي موجوده فيه
[موسيقى]
المميز هذا البركان انه في عده اشياء
بدايه في بحيره كبريتيه تعتبر اكبر بحيره
بكبريتيه موجوده في فوهه بركان بالاضافه
لانه السياح بالعاده بيروحوا له عشان
يشوفوا
نار لونها ازرق موجوده في فوهه البركان
ممكن الواحد يشوفها لو بروح بوقت ظلام
يعني قبل الشروق او بعد الغروب وثالثا
بتشوف حياه الناس المحليه اللي عملهم
متمركز حوالين صناعه الكبريت
السبب اللون الازرق للنار اللي هو درجه
حرارتها يتجاوز 600 درجه مئويه فبالتالي
بهاي الدرجه بكون لون نار الازرق وطريقه
تفاعل النار مع الاكسجين بتعطي هذا اللون
الريحه كتير سيئه وكل شوي الدخان بيجي
علينا الخطوره الاكبر في البركان ويوم
الدخان اللي بتطلع البخار الكبريتي اللي
كل شوي بطلع من الجبل لو الواحد ما كان
معاه قناع الحمايه منه ما حيقدر يتنفس
ممكن يقتنع وهو موجود في الداخل في احد
اللحظات كنت موجود في جوا الفوهه وكان في
غيمه دخان كبريت كبيره وعبتنا لمده يعني
يمكن ربع ثانيه ما كنت حاط القناع يعني
تنفذت من غير القناع وهذاك النفس اثر علي
خلال هذاك اليوم بطريقه سيئه يعني عن جد
كان حارق وسيء او حتى على العينين القائد
اللي كان معنا
وهو بنفس الوقت بشتغل عامل المحاجر اللي
تحت تبعت الكبريت بالرغم من خطورته لكنه
بشكل جزء كبير من طريقه صناعه الدخل للناس
الساكنين في المنطقه تقريبا اغلب الناس
اللي بيسكنوا في اداءك المكان هم ناس
بيشتغلوا داخل البركان بجيبوا الكبريت
بحملوا تقريبا قاعدين نحكي 35 كيلو 40
كيلو من الكبريت بالسلال على كتافهم
بينزلوا ثلاث مرات باليوم عشان بنهايه
اليوم يحصلوا عشرين دولار اللي هو
بيستخدموهم عشان يعيشوا وبدون وجود
البركان يمكن ما يقدروا يعيشوا